how old were you when the first time you
knew you were dangerous I'm from
dagistan and we have traditional like
like most of the old kids they train and
even like when you go to the school in
your class you have like 15 people like
who can give you hard fight it's like
become competition every day go to
school and come back you know when you
fight you fight you fight alone and it
was like big experience to growing in
dagistan like between like 13 and 20th I
remember it was like too much fight in
in Street and when I was like 17 or 18
like I realized I I Can Hurt Like I can
really hurt people and I remember like
father told me like you cannot fight in
street because I teach you all all life
how to become world champion and when
you become 18 19 when you can hurt
people you have to control yourself it's
very dangerous this is almost same thing
like gun you have gun and you have to
control yourself